by the power of castle hate skull i am
hello
and you might be asking yourself mark
how do you look so amazing today what's
going on there's a few different factors
if you're listening to this i'm sorry
you're just gonna have to check out the
video you're gonna have to check out my
instagram page but for those people
watching on youtube i just want to let
you know i'm very excited to announce
that i have a new sponsor
it's my first clothing sponsor this is a
company called oak and stone clothing
you can visit them at
oakenstoneclothing.com
and i am wearing their shirt today they
got a lot of great basic stuffs uh some
other flannel stuff that's a little more
uh you know has more patterns it's a
little bit more
uh eye-catching but you know i love a
good company that has the basics and i'm
just rocking a white basic long sleeve
tee today i'm gonna get into it in a
little bit but i just wanted to announce
that up for it that i'm very excited i
love the owner of this company and i
love the company itself and i hope you
guys are going to help me out by
supporting them use code hello
at checkout or actually just code hella
so
let's start off here
myself full
i wanted to give a shout out to a few
guys
who have been showing me some love the
past couple weeks the boys at north uh
star christian academy merck andrew eli
ryan noah and jerry so i began getting
messages from these different kids
um that were all in high school like yo
what's up we love your stuff you're the
coolest person ever like you're so buff
how do you do it be my daddy etc i'm
like yeah yeah then i noticed i'd click
on their profiles because i like to see
like you know is it somebody just
trolling me or is it an actual human
uh and i saw this
you know they all look like they're
playing baseball at this place called
nca
and
i chatted with um a few of them
and uh one of them invited me to do a
video call the other day and i said
screw it you know i have time right now
i'm gonna call in they were very
enthusiastic i just think that kind of
stuff is cool that i reach people
who are from a younger generation and i
think any guy my age or or whatever i've
always thought it was cool when i was
teaching when i was substitute teaching
uh tutoring and coaching
just to have that bridge to the next
generation especially with young men um
because i think we always need guidance
and we always need mentors not that i'm
positioning myself as a role model but i
like to keep in touch and go hey where i
can give you advice where i can give you
guidance
or just form friendships across
generations i think that's a cool thing
so if it's creepy or cheesy to you
id gaf
and you can spell that out i'm trying to
cuss in the first three minutes of the
youtube that's like the algorithm right
you can't cuss appreciate you okay
not uh undermine ourselves by cussing
after the first three minutes though oh
my god f-bombs left and right so shout
out guys at north star christian academy
rocking the oak and stone clothing i
think it looks phenomenal and you're
going to see more of this every week as
i continue to rock the oak and stone
but we got a little catching up to do
because the last week
we couldn't shoot unfortunately because
i almost killed casey sorry casey you
have it now it's an apology like i
haven't said anything about it's kind of
avoiding the topic i'm like you know but
i'll just do it now yo my bad um
sorry about killing you or whatever but
we cool yeah we're cool okay cool yeah
he was fine um
so i did come in and shoot an episode
with covet i feel really that's actually
the worst part about govid um it felt
like a really long cold it wasn't that
bad had a lot of
nasal congestion and
headache not so much in the lung area
which i think apparently is the new
variant or something you know let's go
with that let's go with that story sure
um you know but i was testing myself
obsessively i was also supposed to go on
to the fighter and the kid that friday
and couldn't do it um you know you get
these at home rapid test and i was just
like how about another one how about
another one how about another one but i
guess they give uh
false negatives are really the thing
that you get not false positive so if
you've got a false positive or a
positive you probably
just have the disease unfortunately so i
feel bad about giving it to casey i feel
bad about giving it to my friend boomer
who i was screaming at with that sketch
recently where i was like i slapped his
head off his shoulders so check that out
my ig if you haven't i love those and
people seem to really like when someone
gets decapitated in my sketches whether
it's me or somebody else it's always a
nice little button and boomer mobley is
the guy behind those amazing special
effects and a lot of the great ideas um
and unfortunately yes i'm
you know sort of the worst case scenario
for hey i'm sick let me scream in your
face for 20 takes in a row
and uh you know probably cover you with
my saliva
and germs so sorry about that boomer but
hey you guys lived and it's fine so like
i don't feel that bad you know somebody
died to be like uh you know i'll take a
little bit of that heat but
as long as you guys are living like i
can move on so i hope you guys can too
because it's not good to live in the
past and just kind of like live with
regrets and animosity towards the people
that you work with
so yeah
now
i did heal in time for the tough mudder
we're just catching up we got stuff to
do i put out this training vlog last
week that i had up my sleeve and i want
to do more of them i think you guys
liked it working with nash from rep
works
he's the man we did some deadlifting we
did some pulling and i wanted to bring
you guys into
my life of training a little more uh i
want to do it more even if i
don't have a special guest i'd love to
do more um people like gregor gallagher
from kinobody is going gonna visit la he
says soon i'd love to get him both on
the show and training maybe do something
with guys like isaiah or bradley martin
you know whoever i can get
to train with and have them impart
knowledge on to you but i also want you
guys to see how i train because
sometimes you can
tell everybody
um you could tell people everything
about your training methodology i can
write it out i can describe to you how i
train but unfortunately until you see
certain things and maybe
you know intensity level is another
thing because people will come to me and
say
i've been working out
x many months and i haven't got the
results that i'm looking for i haven't
gotten bigger what should i do should i
take steroids and it's like you know
that would be one of the many questions
they ask in addition to supplements
but it's always tough to say
what somebody's doing wrong until you
see them lifting
and for a lot of people there is an
intensity level and as you probably know
historically i've been
more of a
high intensity
low volume type of lifter i like to get
in and out and hit it really hard i've
had to switch that up a little bit due
to my shoulder injuries
um
and that's still very effective it's
just not something i'm
normally doing but you know i do think
everyone should experience what high
intensity feels like what it feels like
to really go to failure and not be able
to do another rep
on a certain compound movement with a
gun to your head the metaphorical gun to
your head could you do another rep if
not then out rpe 10 if not
if you could do another rep gun to your
head then you're not at rpe 10 and
you're not giving all that effort and
you haven't gone to failure okay
so did another tough mudder this weekend
um
casey wasn't there to upstage us all and
finish in 30 minutes so we took a nice
leisurely pace with matt mitrione he
dropped out i know that's already been
said i don't feel like harping on the
guy i mean it's a lot to jump into 95
degree heat and
um you know
he actually
he confided to us that he took a viagra
before and he asked me i feel bad cause
i'm like no like
because
i take to dallasville which is uh you
know the generic form of cialis as a
pre-workout you know because they like
to have a a hard d in the gym right sure
so but it also is it's a faster dialer
so it um dilates the blood vessels and
and helps your pump
now
that's a long-acting compound like
cialis
is effective in your body for like 24-36
hours viagra is supposed to be like a
four-hour window so if you've ever taken
it have you ever taken it okay not to
put you on the spot but like it feels
like that thing is like
concentrated in four hours you know it's
like a bigger rush it's a bigger like
maybe you get sort of a head rush maybe
you feel like heat from it you know
um
it's been a while since i've taken it so
i'm not going to do a great job of
describing the exact feeling but let's
just say i can see why you'd feel off a
little bit you know maybe it would
increase your heart rate because if your
uh veins dilate
and
you want you know uh the same amount of
blood
you know like something something else
is gonna have to shift and i think
that's like
uh you know to keep your
heart
up your blood pressure stable and your
veins are bigger i assume your heart has
to like pump harder each
pump
you know versus like if something's
vasoconstricting you have to do more of
it like more frequent so your heart rate
goes up you know on a vasoconstrictor uh
like a nicotine or an adderall or any
sort of still like caffeine um
but
something's often it might make you feel
like uh oh this is you know my heart's
pumping harder even if not more
frequently and i'm sweating more
whatever he dropped out after three
miles and i don't blame him and i also
looked at him and like there's a guy
with nothing to prove athletically like
if you play in the nfl you play d1
college football you play you know you
fight in multiple organizations at a
high level
you don't have to do the tough mudder
and that's kind of a knock against a lot
of these things where it's like you know
i get crossfit competitions and i love
crossfit but you always wonder it's like
you didn't get enough of that in high
school or college or you know people
find that maybe like the competitive
element of uh you know they didn't
compete in college and then it's like
now i'm 35 and i want to be the best
crossfit in the world i don't know
what's your take on it i mean with
specifically with matt if you've beaten
fedor emilianenko you don't have to do
anything else
you know you're good but that like is
that that is something where it's like
i'm not gonna quit or you have that
voice in my head where it's like
i do feel like i have something to prove
you know or people were ripping on me
the last tough mudder for like there was
like footage of like me like missing
going over the thing the first time so
i'm like i'm if anybody's filming i
don't even think anybody's filming but
like there is that voice in my head
um they're like no i know the truth of
like yeah i tried it and then like my
hands are numb so i have to go back and
do it again but like there is that voice
in your head of like no i'm gonna do it
this time even to prove it to yourself
or whatever or getting over the there's
this one thing where you climb
you know uh with just your arms over
this
like body of water that the last couple
tough mudders i fell in right at the end
when you like switch to like the pole
that slides down i fell in and so i was
like this time i gotta finish you know
part of it's your ego
part of it's like reputation or whatever
but yes like if i'm in this position and
that's a pretty cool position to be in
to be like nah nah don't don't care and
i think that also kind of goes to like
the fight that i almost got into the
other week or guys who like start fights
at my age it's like what are you trying
to prove you know what do you what do
you like and again the ufc fighter
analogy there would be sort of like the
last person who'd need to
prove that he can fight people is a
successful heavyweight champion and i
think you see that with guys like
brendan too like
he actually shows a lot of patience with
people who you know inadvertently
disrespect him or whatever and he
doesn't really have a temper that i've
seen in you know one-on-one
confrontation or he's been in situations
like you know another person might like
escalated or feel like
threatened but if you've been there done
that
you can walk away that's cool well you
know what time it is time to talk about
kratom again my favorite nootropic and
stimulant that's all natural and comes
from a plant which you can't say about
many things right so
i use kratom to fire up my brain before
this podcast it's my limitless pill i
love it it's my favorite i use it to get
this amount of energy where i feel like
i have a lot to say and i feel smart and
i feel competent and i like feeling like
that so if you want to feel the same go
to happy hippo herbals.com and use promo
code thick boy with 3cs for 20 not 10
but 20
off
for life use that code as many times as
you want to get as much kratom as you
want just use it responsibly and i
guarantee you you're gonna like the way
you feel okay guys
as i mentioned before i'm super excited
to announce my partnership with oak and
stone clothing
the reason i am excited about it is
because
as a guy who lifts weights as an athlete
rarely do you have
the
kind of cut for clothing that really
suits you well so that's one thing that
i look for
that is hard to find but a company like
oakenstone which is a new company has
tailored their clothing
to guys like me and you um it's
form-fitting stuff cut for the athlete
and it's really high quality
the owner of the company
ricardo
he
sources
the fabric locally and so that's another
thing you look at this and you go it's
high quality it's not going to break
down after a few washes
it's locally sourced it's american
products so if you want to support
america if you're into the whole country
that you live in thing the whole
patriotism thing i want you to check out
oakenstone
oakenstoneclothing.com use use code
hella for 10 off and i'd really
appreciate the support for this podcast
and this new company that has really
high quality clothing uh at a good price
especially given the fact that all this
stuff is locally sourced and he's not
getting materials uh from china and have
it manufactured over there and shipped
over in bulk
you'll feel the difference order some of
this stuff and you will feel that it's
superior i have some of their flannel
shirts too and i own a lot of flannel
shirts these are by far the highest
quality ones that i own and you'll be
seeing me wear more of these shirts
on subsequent episodes and out in public
and on my social media so again go to
oakenstoneclothing.com and use code
hella at checkout bye-bye oh you know i
wanted to bridge this into psychedelics
okay
let's let's let's go down to a hella
psychedelic um
i copy and pasted something i'm gonna
riff a little bit read a little bit off
this because
there was a dude who came up to me who's
been he was at the last tough mudder he
comes up and like first thing he's like
hey want to take some shrooms and i'm
like that doesn't sound like a good idea
to me
because
it is going to be very hot outside we're
outdoors it's dry psychedelics in my
experience
increase your body temperature
especially
at higher doses and
i've lifted weights i remember i'm more
of like a micro not quite a micro dose
like a half dose of lsd let's say like
40 50 micrograms right which is like a
little bit more than a micro dose but
not quite a full dose
it wasn't
the most unpleasant thing i've ever done
like you kind of on lsd you feel the
need to be like active and moving that
feels enjoyable but
i was like i'm sweating a lot and i
could really use like a fan right now
and this i'm in an air-conditioned place
i remember that and that was just my
quick calculus of like am i gonna put
something in my body when it's
already almost 100 degrees it's going to
make me hotter as like i don't have
access to water constantly so i said no
and let's just say
i think that was the right decision
because i saw this guy later on oh
actually i didn't see him later i saw
him at one point he was like shrooms are
kicking in just to know in general
and after that i think he asked me do
shrooms dehydrate you and i was like
yeah yeah they do because they make you
sweat more and p more you know you'll
just notice
and at a certain point i don't know if
you finished i didn't see him afterwards
i didn't see him during the race and we
weren't like
zooming ahead you know
um
so it's possible he dropped out you know
and that's another thing that'll make
you reshift your priorities if you are
doing it out of ego
you know and he also said that he drank
heavily last night also not a good idea
don't undermine yourself don't do these
things
that will put you in a position where
you're already doing something strenuous
and painful and it's going to make it
even more so but because of that i
looked up something
like just said you know went to google
and said taking shrooms or psychedelics
while working out
found this little article
by dr tyler lesher on the maps institute
website the maps institute is dedicated
to helping people find and sustain
balance in their lives
so that they can simultaneously be more
productive and effective at work have
deeper and more fulfilling relationships
and live a more meaningful life now i've
never been to this place before but it
kind of sounds like an interesting
website that i like to peruse so
maybe that's the case for you too i do
want to take some bits from this little
article
want to take your workout to the next
level the benefits of micro dosing might
be the game changer you're looking for
microdosing is the process of taking a
minimal or small amount of one of these
psychedelic compounds blah blah blah
blah blah
such that it does not have a
hallucinogenic effect
the actual dosage is unique to each
person and their different tolerances
but typically range between one-third
and one-tenth
of a gram that would be for mushrooms
micrograms um
you know for lsd would be like 10
micrograms probably to 40 or 50 as i
said that would be the high threshold
because a normal dose is like you know a
tab is typically 100 220 micrograms
for similar reasons some are
experimenting
oh sorry some people are using
microdosing to induce a flow state of
creativity increase focus and extend
cognitive functioning for similar
reasons
some are also experimenting with
microdosing during workouts in fact
research shows that the body tends to
function better during workouts when a
microdose is present in the system
because of the mindful effects that are
produced from psilocybin
it is believed that this effect is
because micro dosing helps to decrease
the stress of daily life improve mood
increase cognition and focus reduce the
rate of perceived exertion
and because it aids in ego dissolution
ego dissolution is the complete loss of
subjective self-identity which is a
critical
aspect for researchers when looking at
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy and
psychosis so
i read that like a run-on sentence but
you know it aids in dissolution period
then ego dissolution is this as a result
micro dosing um
people who micro dose report an increase
in motivation
due to the higher cognitive function
that they experience and they're able to
push more weight run longer and faster
and have their inner voice
telling them to stop that seems to go
away
so
um
you know i'm looking for anything that
adds on to that rather than repeats
itself here's one little thing
the benefits of exercise are profound
for reducing stress increasing body
function improving metabolic profile
the dopamine rush effects
the nucleus
accumbens much greater and the rating of
perceived exertion or rp is much less i
think uh
on
these micro doses of psychedelics right
so basically that already ties into what
we talked about before with rpe you know
your rate of perceived exertion
that goes down so you're pushing harder
but you don't really realize it it's a
sort of natural because your mood is so
good and it has um you know potentially
even anti-inflammatory and
neuroprotectant properties so again
who knows these are all just you know
there's been a study there's been some
speculation i've had good experiences um
in general besides the heat thing
it's the one thing that i would
potentially use again because of like i
used to smoke weed and run
um i've done some sort of physical
exertion while drunk and it just doesn't
feel you know it's like all right we're
drunk let's like have a race or do
something where you're like that doesn't
feel good right and some people tell me
like
i got drunk and then did a bench press
workout it's like that's stupid because
i just like or just do it sober and then
drink afterwards um
something to look into potentially
um
pairing increased performance with
improved cognition and mood allows you
to maximize every rep of exercise this
is all just saying the same thing
boosting all the benefits from your
workout try it out i want you guys to go
take some shrooms take some lsd and just
let me know how it goes make sure to
tell everyone in the gym that you're
doing that right that's the most
important offer to everybody remember
you know like don't
don't bring in the gum if you don't have
enough for the class as your
kindergarten is caring yeah so if you
have lsd make sure to pass it out
at the gym
can we do a liver king meme of the week
can we just
see what's up with this dude
and this is actually more of a serious
one this is this guy uh
mad scientist duffin
on vacation or
am i a hypocrite here just just tell me
i mean i am a jack shirtless dude i own
a supplement company and one of my three
children uh asked me to train with me
and it shows up on a video a few times a
year but this this bothers me yes i want
to have some aspect of physical culture
in all of my children's life because i
want them to challenge themselves also
mentally and emotionally body mind and
soul but more importantly as a parent i
want to empower them and show them that
they can find and forge their own being
so online when people say oh your kids
are going to be the next greatest power
lifters it actually bothers me because
if that happened all of them that would
cause me some level of introspection
what kind of environment am i creating
for them
to to empower them or am i trying to
create mini bees you guys said these
kids look unhappy so
i thought that was really interesting
even though there's some other funny
things that happen of course this guy
cranks out content and
um a lot of it is just like he leans
into the humor i think
the liver king that is
uh
but you know there's some elements of
always like self-promotion there was one
that i was going to show where he's like
you know like hijacking a plane with his
barbarian hat on and stuff like that
a lot of stuff he does is funny this one
just hit me and i thought i'd do a
standalone sort of analysis of what he's
saying because i think it's sort of deep
and there's another guy
mad scientist duffin that i've recently
been watching and he kind of like he
speaks in a way that is counterintuitive
to how he looks
and i love people like that that he kind
of
he looks like this crazy you know
barbarian bro kind of like liver king
but what he's saying is extremely
thoughtful and not that the liver king
isn't smart
or thoughtful but
you know there's an element of like
constant self-promotion and he's always
on message so
i you know it hits a different frequency
for me
this guy is saying something that i
think is really thoughtful and i wanted
to touch on that and we also don't know
because we're looking at a clip of the
liver king like forcing his kids to work
out and there was another one this week
where he like
he had this video where they're buried
understand i don't know how much you
how much you follow the liver game but
like there was this controversy over him
burying his kids like neck deep in sand
and like kicking sand in their face
allegedly um and the video kind of
starts off with like
if my kids don't do what the liver king
says that's a terrible king imitation by
the way because i know he has like a
lisp if my kids don't do what the liver
king says i kick sand in their faith and
this is what happens consequences to my
actions you know so he's kind of playing
this like authoritarian dad role you
know as well um you know and showcasing
like how he uses
sadistic punishment for his kids which
again we don't know the level of joking
we don't know the sincerity level you'd
actually have to like
be around him to see that
but
i'm going to break down what mad
scientist duffin says as if
you know this is a serious thing where
he is kind of forcing his kids
to exercise before they go into a museum
or whatever he says
people will comment online and say
oh your kids are going to be the next
greatest power lifters right and often
that is the case where you have you know
you're a doctor and your kid's a doctor
or they follow in the footsteps um and
that could happen organically but
sometimes do
uh your parents do
place pressure on their kids to do a
certain thing
and
i think it's an interesting sort of
philosophical inquiry to like do you owe
your kids a childhood you owe your kids
a choice should they have the choice to
compete in sports should they choose the
sports that they
compete in i
growing up i didn't feel a tremendous
amount of pressure but i felt like
um
i had to do something and i think that's
more like your kids you know your
parents like stay out of the house like
i don't want you coming back and doing
nothing and and i think that that was a
good amount of pressure but if i said i
don't want to play football anymore or
you know i want to play water polo
instead that was left up to me so i
guess that's a balance of
autonomy and guidance um and certain
boundaries of like you're going to do
something and maybe it was just one
sport or whatever but i ended up
swimming wrestling playing football and
at least in from my perspective i felt
like i had a choice i just don't know
what would have happened had i not done
anything but i remember
my parents are accomplished swimmers
and they kind of like pushed me into
doing swimming
at young ages even though i wouldn't
have sought that out and i kind of like
never fully
fell in love with it and i was okay at
it you win some ribbons and races and
you feel good about it and i really
think it's tremendous exercise to get
good at everybody should you know have
swing proficiency so you don't drown and
it's fantastic cardiovascular and uh you
know anaerobic exercise
but
i can easily see how that would veer
into kind of
undermining your sense of uh you know
happiness and enjoyment as a child i
know a friend of mine
used to be a professional oh she still
is like a professional dancer in the
sense that she gives lessons but um and
she was a backup dancer for beyonce and
was very accomplished as a backup dancer
and would tell me that her
dad would sort of be very strict growing
up and like take her outside and like
make her do like these things in the
rain like over and over and over again
to perfect it kind of like that you know
you can imagine like the women's
gymnastics team or whatever
and i do feel like that does
you know
produce athletes who kind of give up
like michaela maroney comes to mind and
i know there was a whole different thing
obviously she was like
molested by this
disgusting human of a uh you know their
team doctor who would like
essentially
you know abuse all these girls for years
and they would listen to her that's
another terrible layer on i just wonder
if like it was also just like if you're
competing for a gold medal at 15 and all
that pressure and all that stress and
all that hours and hours and hours and
demanding of perfection if that makes
you become an adult and say i never want
to do that again
i don't know good question put your
responses there in the comments make
friends in the comments as crystalia
says and tell me if you have kids what's
your approach if you don't and you plan
on it what do you think you will do
with these hypothetical children
once they're of the age where they can
play sports you know but i would force
my kids to lift weights like at least
get the basics down because that can be
translated to other things i don't know
it's you know it's just an interesting
question that's why i wanted to pose it
can we do a mark harley meme of the week
can we just can we do it
you know
every week daniel rabone comes through
with some bangers i want to give some
other people some love before
i hit you with some d rabone classics
but
here we have a nice office meme
with steve carell that 80's pick that
one guy that's seen every mark harley ig
story ha hilarious shaking my hand
classic and then we had
uh hala mark blurry and hella mark healy
from danny rabone i these are simple but
like a lot of people love the heller
mark blurry one they were like i don't
know why that or the hell of marquilli
one too um
i got the healey's on remember healey's
remember that was a thing oh yeah and we
both we both uh did inline skating and i
know you still do that at a very high
level but like didn't it kind of seem
like when those came out like having you
know it's like i'm trying to grind on
rails you guys are like rolling on the
ground and you think that's cool it just
seemed like this cheap cop out i don't
know
yeah there were heelys and then there
were also remember soap shoes
there's shoes with grind plates man yeah
and it's like the same principle i don't
know just like i never wanted them
because i felt like i felt attacked yeah
we got to get use of heelys i do just
seeing this yes you're right actually we
gotta get to get some healing around the
studio um
all right so
i wanted to do a quick
bro science academy
my boy austin
who's um
he he's a music producer
he does mixing super talented guy who i
met actually he came up he was like
after i went on the fight on the kid the
first time
i you know this is the most famous i
felt i think like in like one day like
three people were like hey you're in the
fight of the kid you're the fighter the
kid it was all at the 24 hour fitness in
truman oaks but you know made me feel
good austin is one of these guys
and uh i struck up a relationship
with him we talk a lot he's a really
cool guy and
um he hit me
with a question about squatting that i
thought was really good
and i wanted to pass on here and the
question is what you think about this
let's just watch this video real quick
so struggling to increase your squat um
basically
he's recommending a thing called the
anderson squat where you start with a
specific weight
at a pin let's say it's halfway down
um
and you're trying to max out of this
weight so once you can get up to three
to four reps you put it down lower you
know another few inches right so now
you can hopefully max out at that range
of motion when you get up to be able to
do three or four you repeat the process
and just work from wherever you're at
wherever you can get that weight down to
your full range of motion where you
don't need a pen where you can just go
full astergrass or below parallel or
whatever you want so he said what you
think about this now i know why he's
asking that because
a lot of times partial reps are
demonized and a lot of these like gym
fail videos that i show you are people
sort of cluelessly doing partial reps
and in general
i do think
that
nine times out of ten i'm gonna
recommend if i see somebody doing
partial reps it's like well they're
doing it wrong and they shouldn't be
doing that they should learn how to go
through a full range of motion and
commit to that and experience
hypertrophy from it because using
partial reps is sort of an advanced
technique right so for the average
person that you see doing partial reps
it's usually out of ego out of
incompetence out of not knowing how to
do it right and you can see as i always
point out it's like it's not like the
biggest guys in the gym doing this and
maybe if they were
you'd
pay attention and go what exactly is
going on here but you don't get big
99.9 of the time without some sort of
system in place
i've used partial rep systematically
before in this power factor training
it's really goofy in some ways and like
older dudes give me [ __ ] as i told you
the story about but like it actually
worked it got me stronger but the thing
is you have to overload something you
can't just keep doing the same weight in
the same range of motion week after week
after week so here's what i wrote to him
and i'll expand upon that a little bit i
just thought you know i did a decent job
of writing it why not you want to use my
writing in private to share with you in
public you could definitely use
techniques like that
effectively as a form of progressive
overload since progressive overload is
just a given variable you're pushing
over time more weight more reps more
sets more frequency less rest etc and in
this case you'd be overloading the range
of motion on a fixed weight rather than
loading the weight on a fixed
range of motion rather than overloading
the weight on a fixed range motion right
half or partial reps can be effective if
they're part of an actual program but
usually people putting
cutting their range of motion short or
doing it purely out of ego and
incompetent is what i wrote but
incompetence is what i meant
so
again
you're overloading something right so
rom could be that variable that you're
overloading over time you're making it
harder you're using more range of motion
week after week after week got it
be systematic and you can do that too
because look if you can like you know if
i can support 600 pounds over my head
like i have strong shoulders
how did i get there probably by starting
with 300 pounds and then adding a little
bit there are you know case studies of
people doing that where they literally
just use static holds to increase their
strength something's happening right
um yes
i have a question yeah um is there any
value here just uh in using those pins
like to just do like let's say there's a
weight that you want and you're just
using
just the negative and then getting to
that yes yeah that's a really good
question um
because we'll see that for example like
commonly and something that i've used
um because the the negative is extremely
stressful and does more muscle damage so
if you're like achieving hypertrophy
through muscle damage um it's something
that i've actually had to cut down on
doing like
negatives and four straps because it's
very taxing it's very fatiguing right
but you could certainly like you know
because there's there's gonna be a
certain amount of weight that you can't
hold for a negative you know put a
thousand pounds on a bench press like
it's just going to fall at the speed of
gravity you know um but somewhere
between that with a with something
that's so easy it's ridiculous on the
way down and something super hard would
be a weight that'd be like you could
have somebody help you know of course it
it requires you to um
you know get the weight up so that has
to be a lift that you can either get a
partner or do on your own
heavy curling is one that i really like
to use right you do like a cheat curl
you're essentially like you know
cheating your way up and then you
control it on the way down so if you get
like 135 or something which is heavy for
a lot of people
um
i can do it for a strict set of eight
it's no big deal but i'm just saying
like i have big biceps not everybody
does uh you can cheat your way up and go
down right it's hard to like cheat your
way up into a
a bench press but um
you could set pins and just go um you
know
control the weight do partials do
negatives um
you know and slowly overload that over
time it's just
you know should you be doing that if you
haven't maxed out like you know hit a
plateau and do that don't start off
doing it i think that's most people's
problem is i still haven't mastered the
basics
help i'm on steroids
so
you know
the first topic of the day is i want
people to do more of their own reasons
i've been helping people lately and it's
like i'll answer their questions and
then it's like they have like 20 more
questions and i just find myself being
like hey google is your friend okay you
know if you like if i for example
somebody was like i showed them where to
get hcg
the needle to use to inject it like how
much to mix like all these different
things and then they're like
i injected it with like intramuscularly
with a 3cc needle now if you don't know
anything about the world of hcg it's an
ancillary
compound that's used to restart your own
nuts and you inject it subcutaneously
into your belly fat now
i know some of these things might be
like they're obvious to me but not
obvious to others but i just feel like
people get information from me and just
stop there or they don't get any
information and just come to me and have
like all these follow-up questions and i
like doing it but i also want to
encourage people in general to be
curious because there is so many
like
different opinions about things you know
somebody's asking like what's the right
dose of trend i'm you know helping
somebody i don't sell steroids i empower
other people to buy them on their own
um
but you know they'll ask me things like
how much trend should i take and i i
don't know
i really don't know i can tell you what
i've taken you know between 100
milligrams a week and 700 recently and i
could tell you generally
you know
i didn't die that's all i could say but
you know obviously there was some some
upper threshold side effects that
interfered with my workout and didn't
make it feel fun with the headaches and
the blood pressure
and the just you know the extreme
horniness
i'll throw that out there um you know
these androgens do have an effect on
your brain that makes sleeping difficult
and uh not jerking off also difficult uh
luckily it was only for a week and did
ruin my life but
uh you see changes and on a hundred
you're gonna notice
you know i did notice an effect and i
did notice some night sweats you kind of
go okay i know this is in my body and
looking back at some pics i'm like okay
i can see the kind of look you're going
for but you know you have this range i
don't know because you're going to have
to experiment on your own
and see what dif you know some people
would say oh hundreds nothing you got at
least start with 300.
you know some people say you only should
start at 500 tests i've never even taken
500 tests i've taken 400 for like a
month and felt like it was too much um
so
there are varying opinions out there and
i ultimately just think
you're going to have to be if you want
to go down that road you know unless you
want to hire a full-time coach and fully
trust this guy there's an element of
like research and experimentation that
you kind of just have to buy into
and do yourself up that's not really
what i wanted to talk about i wanted to
talk about
dball there's this great um
video that i watched between tony huge
and some other guys
tony huge is a controversial character
in the world of
anabolics and youtube because he like
he's super into sarms and like
experimenting on himself like i just
mentioned but sort of to an extreme and
he helped this guy kenny ko gain like
you know 25 pounds of like muscle in a
week
using steroids insulin sarms growth
hormone like you know throw everything
at somebody so much like you know weight
can they put on that's non-fat tissue it
might be a lot of water but it's very
interesting to experiment with that he
recently had a heart attack
you know so this is one of these guys
where it's like okay maybe you know when
you're approaching 50 years old and
doing even more extreme things than i
have um
and i'm not saying that steroids caused
it you know i think people do have these
defects that kind of get exposed you
know like that guy ziz who's one of the
most famous like
you know pioneers of fitness um did a
few cycles in his early 20s and died
because he had like a hole in his heart
from what i understand i don't know what
the exact condition was but you know
it's something to know ahead of time too
because i don't think that like your
heart's not going to give out from a few
cycles if you have a healthy heart but
if you have a defect it could be exposed
and and kill you you know with a
number of doses at a at a certain level
of
um compound administration that just
would be totally fine for some someone
else so there's always that risk and i
always try to tell people it's like you
know it's a small percent chance but it
is it's not zero
and um
anyway they had a whole podcast on dball
now
i've gotten i remember some there were
some comments that i've seen online like
when i was doing the angelone only cycle
and the d-ball
in the middle of that i actually took
d-bot and tell you guys but i like i ran
out of angel and it was there's more
coming on the way
and
um
like from a vendor that's normally never
late but like there was a gap and i had
d boss i'm like let me just experiment
with the same dose doing d-ball
because that you know also is something
that i've been researching like a d-ball
only cycle it's when i first heard about
it it's like you make fun of the guy in
high school who's doing a d-ball only
cycle who
uh you know takes
d-ball gains a bunch of weight then
loses it all and he's not really serious
and it's one of these guys who's like i
don't want to inject right that's not me
but the more i learn about it
you know it could be used as a test base
because it converts to estrogen and
there's also
um so you want that right you want that
neural protective factor of estrogen and
apparently it can help uh you know it
just helps you gain muscle um if you're
experiencing estrogenic side effects and
you have to take ancillaries um
you know because you don't want
the puffiness the guy know the act
whatever it is
you should be taking the minimum because
ultimately estrogen does help you now
this is one of those compounds it's like
the oldest old school the eastern
europeans had tariniball do you know
anything about triniball
casey i do not okay because it's like
it's what john jones popped for and it
was like oh right that sounded familiar
that's right
both of them test and uh sorry their
test derivatives triniball and dianaball
and tariniball is kind of known as a dry
d-ball in the sense that it doesn't
convert to estrogen and therefore
doesn't
make you retain water
and this was the drug de jour it's an
oral steroid of the eastern bloc
countries and uh you know responsible
for how they smashed all those world
records and dianaball was like the
american response to that that they used
to like dope american athletes and for a
while
um you know golden era bodybuilders
growing up
in my understanding the 60s and 70s you
could just go to the doctor and be like
can i get some dianaball and they'd
prescribe it to you and um
you know currently you can go to
thailand and it's like pharmaceutically
produced and you can get you know 510
milligram tablets for
like 40 bucks right so it's super cheap
and it's thought of as a bulking agent
but um
you know that you'd combine with other
things
it's something that
i'm
wanting to experiment more with because
that guy tayan clark who i mentioned uh
his hair loss protocol and he has some
really interesting like unique insights
into certain compounds he was like you
don't lose hair on dianaball and you
kind of look back at these golden arrow
bodybuilders like yeah they did really
have nice hair you know
um
and it's sort of surprising because you
think of it as like a stronger compound
in your mind like it was one of the
first things i take i took deca dee ball
test gained a bunch of weight and was
kind of like oh no i don't want to do
these watery drugs on their own but
taking an angelone and taking d-ball
alone i actually experienced less of
that bloat you feel fullness but i
didn't feel like i was retaining
excessive water and just felt like it
was a nice pleasant compound to be on
there's a mood-enhancing effect and also
um
supposedly you know this is like an
hour-long podcast that i'm trying to
synopsize and draw
some little tidbits from but
they've studied it up to 100 milligrams
in you know a you know clinical settings
and they'd give like 10 or 15 milligrams
to some of these patients
and there'd be like no liver value um
alterations so that's what you're really
looking at when you
talk about liver toxic steroids it's
like um you know
is this
is this liver toxic is it you know
messing up my liver um
is it causing these side effects now
most liver toxic orals reverse after you
stop taking them right so you could take
it and within like a week or something
your liver values return to normal it's
apparently very hard to destroy your
liver
with just steroids possible but more
likely you know if you're an alcoholic
right that's going to be
more likely to actually destroy your
liver over time because it's a very
resilient organ but i was unaware
they're like oh you can take these small
doses maybe even as a you know what
would be that
equivalent a
a testosterone replacement equivalent of
dianabol could be like 15 or 20
milligrams where you'd get this positive
anabolic effect
without actually triggering some of
these markers that you'd consider
unhealthy and then some of these guys
apparently back in the day used to take
like 100 200 300 milligram which sounds
like an insane dose
but
that's like all they had you know so
it's like now everybody combines all
these different things that it might add
up to
5000 milligrams whatever a week but if
all you had was 300 milligrams of if all
you had is dianabol and you take 300
milligrams a day
it's not that much different than taking
like a really large amount of tests and
stacking other things on it so you go
back you look at these physiques
there is some pretty impressive things
that these old school bodybuilders did
on just test deca and d-ball
and um it reiterates something that
i said before which is i believe when
you combine you know you get these
progestogenic and estrogenic side
effects with something like deca when
you combine it with test or if you
combine test and dball those are two
compounds that convert to estradiol so
you're going to magnify those effects
but if you take them on their own
perhaps you can avoid some of those side
effects so it's changed my thinking
and i just wanted to put that in the
category of like
yes all steroids are bad to some degree
but when you start reading more about
them and start becoming more nuanced and
start going okay but which ones are
going to be you know have the least side
effects for me and what is the dose that
i can take to avoid these really severe
um
side effects some interesting things
come up where you can go oh i'm almost
i'm almost healthy on this [ __ ] like you
know trt there's not a lot of people out
there that are going trt is toxic for
you at 150 milligrams or even you know
300 400 500 it's one of the safest
things to take because it's bio
identical
and isn't going you know your body is
accustomed to processing it in your
liver versus some other even injectable
steroids still have to go through your
liver at some point
and uh you know your body isn't
accustomed to processing
that compound so
if you look up the dball podcast
and you see something with tony huge i
encourage you to listen to this and have
your mind blown if you're into
anabolics to any degree i think there's
always interesting insights when you get
people who like really kind of
question our basic assumptions about
what a compound does and what it's used
for
um
you know that you can take like dball as
a pre-workout
there's a lot of stuff you can you can
get from this podcast that i thought was
really cool what do we have left
jfc how about oh
a little hell of chef harley here
shout out to my boy grego gallagher you
know i bought these he sees that i use
this stuff and he'll send me more stuff
he's very
generous and uh and a great guy to talk
training with and just general
approaches especially if you're a natty
guy he's built up some
tremendous strength and impressive
physique almaty and this is the one of
the things that i picked up from him
just a morning scoop of collagen protein
in your coffee so here's just a coffee i
happen to have on hand i'll make a
single cup of it i like my caffeine in
the morning you mix that in it pairs
really well and it's something that
apparently you stop producing collagen
like before this i was aware okay you
should supplement collagen
but since getting into this it's
something i could see myself doing more
every day to get a little bit you know
scoops like 20 grams there's nothing
excessive you can use a pre-workout um
so you're like semi-fasted right or you
know instead of a big breakfast you can
have something like this i really enjoy
it because it's both filling and you get
the coffee like mixing things with
coffee
and
you get this benefit of
you know muscle recovery skin and joints
digestive function there are benefits
taking collagen and apparently after a
certain age i off the top of my head i
think it's like 25 we start producing
less right so our skin is less elastic
you know your hair is lower quality it's
whatever um
i think you know this plus the growth
hormone that i'm taking should be a
pretty good combination as far as just
making me look hot but i wanted to put
you under this
it's uh you know because it's reasonably
priced i think everybody has coffee and
it's just a quick little combination
that you can just sort of get something
in you as far as protein which is good
for fitness and then also have this
benefit of um you know enhancing your
appearance and your recovery so check it
out
little hack there and what do we have
finally
do we even have anything let's do it
this is why we can't have nice gyms
it's at the very bottom there
bully
so this guy's he's setting up he's
standing on plates to dead lift
what looks like seven or eight plates so
it's either 675 or 765
and the funny part is got this like
american flag bandana and what does this
shirt say naturally strong
no steroids
um
do you see what the rest of his shirt
actually says yeah not a steroid taking
phony not a steroid taking phony so this
guy walks into the gym and of course his
physique is terrible he looks like
spongebob squarepants
and uh
it's actually hard to tell whether this
is
like a joke or not but
here's the here's the pros for this guy
not being a joke is he kind of just
looks like the kind of guy who would
wear an american flag t-shirt with a
handwritten message on the back you know
uh saying basically everyone who takes
steroids as a [ __ ] because that's a
common sentiment like people message me
like you're a cheater and a [ __ ] for
taking steroids i'm like okay sounds
good
i've never had like an amazing looking
natural bodybuilder told me that but you
know some weird dudes like this might
get that in their head and pass that
along to me um and also people really do
that like now i again i believe in
partial reps i think it's great to
have a system in which you can
incorporate something like rack
deadlifts just to experience a super
heavy weight he probably moved that
weight would you say two inches
less
i go one an eighth of an inch an eighth
of an inch so it's almost like yeah like
he might have created space from the
bars that it was sitting on but as far
as any actual range of motion
just not something to be proud of and so
i'm kind of like it could be fake maybe
this guy's punking me and it's super
funny and i don't know that he's this
gym comedian who's super amazing in
stealth mode but
my instinct is this guy really believes
his own hype thinks he's super strong
for you know basically being able to
hold on to eight plates with straps
and buddy
you look like dog [ __ ]
okay
and then finally this one is a little
bit more serious here's a
a guy rushing up to get this girl
looks like he's not because the
animosity comes from she goes i got it i
got it i got it
the queen of i got it she's squatting
three plates which is a lot right so
obviously she knows what she's doing
she's hitting full depth her form looks
really good but the bar is traveling up
and this is something that
every advanced lifter
shout out my friend todd who always
seems to have some story about like
somebody touching his three plate bench
press and over the weekend he said with
this video where
he's throwing himself 315 on incline and
somebody like as he like unracks it
somebody like puts this weight right in
front of the
the camera it was like i'm like this has
to be set up you know but of course it
wasn't it's just like 315 karma
but people will do this they'll see you
they'll see comedy lifter especially
guys to girls and again
i don't believe in the whole like you
know all men are misogynists and men are
terrible and just you know totally
invading my space like but it happens at
the gym right this guy shouldn't be
doing that because she's got it and a
lot of guys can't handle like competent
strong female lifters and i've just seen
examples of that where like you know
some girl like my friend lexi is way
stronger than a lot of these guys who
like slide into her dms and try to give
her lifting advice and it's like dude
you can't even lift as much as her back
off plus her form's good so this guy
runs up to her
and tries to spot her and she's yelling
at him and i like that response i like
that energy set that boundary and i was
just in the zoo culture
hearing this one guy
get chewed out like one guy was like
spotting him
and like he touched the bar coming up on
like you know let's say like a 365 bench
press something pretty substantial
but like you know
you really the real principle is don't
touch it until it starts going back
because if it's just stalled out and
nobody said anything that person
believes they can get the rep so you
have to back off and wait till it the
moment that it starts going backwards
because then you're not going to get it
but this guy touched it on the way up
and i was like with an earshot of him
giving him this dressing down like don't
ever touch the bar i almost you're like
you know but it's like that's how people
feel you know people get emotional
and uh if somebody were to for example
touch my lift
that would be grounds for fighting you
know and am i gonna fight you in this
oak and stone clothes no i'm gonna take
it off i'm gonna go what's up bro you
want to touch you touch my lift you
touch my lift
i just i think it's crazy that you think
you can just touch my lift like that and
have no consequences okay
you thought i was popping out of the
strip before check it out now dude
oak and stone oak and yolked is what
we're talking about
code hello